helping women successfully thrive in
their careers and in life we've got tips
on how to win on your terms in Corporate
America shared by a woman who is the
senior VP of diversity equity and
inclusion at United Health Group
sis you got this Joy Fitzgerald is a
coach best-selling author and corporate
leader she pulls together a wealth of
experiences to help women live their
purpose without fear or compromise she
wants women to stop striving for
Perfection start believing their best is
good enough first I want to tell ladies
just kill the negative self-taught drown
out all the rhetoric that is telling you
it's too late you don't have enough time
you're too busy you can't do it you
won't be successful in many cases we
have not achieved our aspirations
because it's our own noise playing in
our head that's preventing us from
reaching our goals invest in
relationship Capital she calls this
career and life differentiators create
good relationships with key decision
makers and find a good Mentor you need
sponsors people that are talking about
you in the rooms that you aren't able to
access so that you can have the capital
but also the emotional but also
promotional business ability to achieve
your dreams be memorable for all the
right reasons never sit in the back of
the room
if you're sitting on the last
why should an organization have top of
mind for their next leadership level or
their neat next leadership role
and remember ladies every time you step
outside of yourself in your comfort zone
you're opening yourself up for new
experiences that help you grow as an
individual